yes with an F yes with an F okay so well
well learn what the f is today I guess
okay so our polar codes practical as I
said yesterday in the short talk by
practical I mean can we build a chip
that implements a decoder okay and then
will this chip have good complexity and
it'll be fast enough and all these
things so this is what we left off
yesterday pointer way yes we left off
yesterday polar codes can achieve
capacity with two caveats you have to
use this v of cancellation decoding
algorithm and this is only happens as
the block length gets really large so
what does this mean well successive
cancellation is really slow and we'll
see why I'll go through the algorithm a
little bit it's bit by bit you have to
decode every bit in order and this makes
things really slow the second problem is
what happens at moderate code lengths
well the performance is worse than LDPC
codes that's what I mean by mediocre
performance now things do get really
good if you have a million bits or more
okay so where were we when we started
this this work we were looking at a
situation of a decoder in hardware where
you can get a few single-digit megabits
per second too slow for any practical
application and what if you wanted to
then have a really long code to get some
performance back you really couldn't do
that because you couldn't build imagine
building an LDPC decoder with a million
nodes that would be impractical so
something had to had to be done at all
I'll try to give you an overview of the
progress towards practical hardware
polar decoders okay so we'll start off
with a very brief introduction to
channel polarization and polar codes
this here is the only equation in the
entire talk right there first and last
okay so imagine you want to transmit two
bits over a channel W so let's say I
send a bit u0 over Channel W and I'll
send you bit u1 over the same channel W
and I received noisy versions y0 and y1
now there's no reason to believe that
you have any more information about u0
or you want than the other thing they're
equally reliable and this is the first
and last inequality you'll see in the
talk
let's play a trick now instead of
sending you zero and you one we'll send
you one over the channel and then the
XOR of you zero new one over the channel
and now things are it'll be interesting
because you see you one appears in both
Y zero one white one so we have just a
little bit more information about you
one than we do about you zero okay so in
a sense you can think of having now two
channels one's a little bit better and
the other one's a little bit worse than
before you can keep doing this
recursively and build bigger and bigger
constructions for longer blocks here's
one for eight bits and what will happen
is is that the different bit positions
will polarize some will become a lot
better it's only become a lot worse and
if you do this for you know a very long
block lengths some of the bits will come
become so good that they're effectively
perfect and some will become so bad that
they're effectively horrible and
unreliable and you can transmit any
information over those so how do you
build the polar code well I find the K
best positions most reliable positions
and I stuff my data bits ok data bits
into those positions so here would be
three five six and seven
and then I say to other their other
positions are never useful salt is
freeze them and put zeros on them okay
that's how you build a code out of this
this construction and the interesting
thing is as the block length gets really
really long the proportion of bit
positions that are reliable are is
actually the channel capacity okay so I
want to look at decoding and this is how
successive cancellation decoding works I
want to explain to you why it's so slow
you're going to estimate the bits given
some soft information here estimate the
bits one at time so first of all s2 made
zero one and then two and then three and
so the way this works is that estimates
of previous bits get fed back into the
decoder and then are used to estimate
the next bit so you can see for example
it's fast forward to the process of
finding estimate for bit six you see
that there's inputs to this graph here
are gonna have the estimates for
previous bits they're gonna be needed to
be known so you have to do do one bit at
a time now here's a snapshot at a point
in time it was actually a small mistake
here but anyway no there's no mistake
here okay you see that there's two kinds
of decoding nodes blue lawns and green
ones let's call the the blue function f
because we're not very very originals we
called it function f it's basically a
check check note if you're familiar with
Eldon C decoding and has two inputs soft
inputs and a soft output now once we get
an estimate for 4-bit six we can ask to
make bits seven and here we're gonna use
again the soft input and here we'll use
all this green function call this
function G and this is basically like a
variable node indelicacy decoding with
one difference so it's either an
addition of this soft input or a
subtraction of the soft input under the
control of a bit which tells you to add
or subtract and that bit is going to be
one of the previous estimates of the
bits L or various partial sums of
previously estimated bits okay that's
that's where the successive nature comes
into this okay so we looked at this and
we know it's a couple of things first of
all how many of these processing nodes
either these function FS or function G's
how many do you need well it looks like
there's an login of them okay that
sounds like an awful lot especially if
you want to build a decoder with a
million a million bits so you can't
really build 20 million process signal
just impractical okay so the first thing
we realized that you actually don't have
to because of the successive nature of
this thing the scheduling works out such
that most of this tree is not doing it
this hardness graph is really not
computing anything at any given time and
so instead of n log and processing
elements you really need on the order of
an okay so that's an improvement it's
still not good because you still don't
want to build a million a million
processing elements okay but what we
looked at the schedule more carefully we
realize that if you look at here's let's
say a code for 1024 bits and I really
should be building on the order of well
depends how you define processing
elements but we here we define it as you
would need 512 so and over two
processing elements too to get the full
decoding what if we decided to use less
than that number what if we wanted to
use a small fraction of that now you can
always do that an LDPC code you can
always build a decoder with less than
and variable nodes and in my skate check
nodes but then you suffer some
throughput loss and so what we notice
though is it's an sed coding is when you
start reducing the num reducing the
number of processing elements you don't
actually see a corresponding decrease in
Troopa now explain why so this blue
curve is the utilization of my
processing elements of my hardware and
if k if I have only a very very small
number of bees or they're heavily used
but as I add bees very quickly the
utilization of the whole decoder goes
down okay so there's a lot of things
they're saying they're idle doing
nothing so let's suggest so I really
don't need that many processing elements
so how many do I actually need well
let's define the maximum possible
throughput you could get out of a
decoder using n over two processing
elements as one okay and then this red
curve will tell you the fraction of that
throughput you could get by using less
than than that number of us in elements
and we find for a 1k code if you use a
64 processing elements you get about 95
percent of the maximum possible
throughput so there's really no loss for
building we call a semi parallel ASE
decoder well the interesting thing
although I didn't graph it here but we
do have a graph what happens when you
scale and to be very large well believe
it or not you get a curve it looks
almost exactly the same so for N equals
a million bits you need 64 128 maybe 200
or so pease and you get almost all the
throughput possible okay so you don't
need the punchline is you don't need n
over 2 on the order of n crossing
elements you need a constant number of
processing elements in that constant is
usually very small compared to the code
length so that was the first big result
ok and that resulted in an ASIC this we
believe is the first polar decoder chip
for a code of length 1024 bits rate 1/2
we did it in 180 nanometer CMOS and I
think the interesting number to look at
is the throughput in terms of
information bits per second was about
50/50 megabit per second okay so this
was done with 64 Pease there are the
bees and circles in the chip and the
rest of the chip is memory okay
so the interesting thing about polar
codes it seems that you don't really
need a lot of logic logic gates is
pretty negligible it's gonna turn out
turns out most of the polar decoder is
just memory okay so then we ask the
question can you scale this up and turns
out that last architecture you couldn't
scale we didn't do something very
efficiently so we figured out how to fix
that and then we started looking at that
new architecture which is related to the
last one and we implemented this on
FPGAs and we see now we can scale up the
code Lane up to about a million bits and
if you look at the numbers here let's
try to understand them look-up tables
you think of this number as being
proportional to the number of logic
gates okay so this is a the logic and
then flip-flops and RAM are memory okay
and you see that the logic doesn't
really change too much a little bit when
you go up two very long lanes but a
really very very modest number of
processing resources in terms of logic
gates and same thing with the flip-flops
it stays relatively constant what does
change of course is Ram you need need to
store the metrics somewhere and for very
long input blocks you need of course
lots of RAM but that's ok it's expected
so this just goes to show that a polar
decoder is a bunch of memory and almost
no logic whatsoever so we can clock this
at about 150 makers which is OK for an
FPGA it things get a little congested
when he gets a very long late so it
drops a little bit but not too much and
ok we get about 50 megabit per second ok
that's good we answered the first
question can you build a sense of
Catalan decoder for million mid polar
codes yeah you can if it's on FPGA and
it's fairly modest hardware ok so this
is a snapshot of where we were at after
that first generation of SAE decoder
hardware so here we were about 50
megabits per second this is actually our
original ASIC if you were to implement
it's the same architecture for rate of
point now in a high rate code you'd
probably get about 80 or 90 megabit per
second and then ok Pamuk who was one of
eric and students had some nice tricks
and he got a similar
kind of architecture up to about 100
megabits per second so that's the
snapshot it we were after the first
generation 100 megabits per second okay
and you could do long coats pretty good
but we want to do more you know from
yesterday's talk we could go to 100
gigabits per second so where's the gap
so how do we get from 100 megabits per
second to a hundred gigs and get this
1,000 times throughput improvement okay
so to understand that I think it's
useful to view the graph as a tree it's
a different representation and let's
show you how to do that so we'll take
group so we'll start off at the left the
bits we'll call those groups of 1 and
then we'll start grouping groups of 2
and then 4 then bigger as you go okay
and let's start replacing these with
some nodes so here we have in this case
this is a pretty cooktop polar code but
there are frozen bits here and these are
information bits these 3 okay
so let's draw the frozen bits as white
circles and the information bits as
black circles now if I have a note here
that has two child nodes that are both
white we'll just call it color that one
white and same thing if you have two
black will color that one black and if
you have situation where it's mixed and
we'll call it color of gray so you see
we have now the next level of the tree
some white black and some mixed nodes
here and then we can keep doing that
same rule until we get a tree that looks
like this and we're going to just use
some thicker lines to indicate that as
you get to the right of the tree towards
the root you're sending vectors of it
instead of just single values and you
have these these fat links okay now
let's turn this thing over on its side
and look at the first thing we can do to
improve the throughput or that decrease
the latency of the SD decoding algorithm
and this is a nice idea from almond
arias T and Shashank called simplified
successive cancellation decoding it's
actually a very clever idea take a look
at this subtree here okay this subtree
here consists of the bottom route the
the leaves here just frozen bits so why
should I have to when I get to this
point here decode this tree successfully
first this one then send information
back here and send it back down there
I already know the answers I know the
answers here are frozen yeah you said if
there are two whites you have a white
yeah this is maybe not following the
same coloring rules last slide that's
right I think it's don't think it said
important but that's a good point that's
a great point
what is frozen okay
so why should you have to decode frozen
bits I know their value they're going to
be zero okay so just don't bother
decoding them and the same thing with
these guys here their information bits I
don't have to decode them actually is a
nice rule I can just take a threshold
and take the hard decisions there okay
now it's very useful to think about this
in a slightly different way think about
this guy on the left as a rate zero code
okay and think about the just decoding
just put placing these values with zeros
as a simplified decoder for that little
rate zero code that lives there okay
it's a possibly actually adds up for me
a parallel decoder the rule is I just
put two zeros here instead of fibula
that's a zero and then figuring that
one's a zero afterwards successively
okay same thing would this rate one code
I can replace this with a simplified
parallel decoder for this little rate
one code okay so I end up with a prune
tree where I do less successive
cancellation and things are going to be
faster okay very nice idea so we took
that idea and started improving it and
going a little further take a look at
some other structures here we notice
that there are other codes that live
inside this big polar code so this left
tree here is actually a repetition code
and the nice thing about repetition code
is we have nice parallel decoders for
them you mean we have to restrict the
the the size of the code that we that we
identified but if you do that then you
can completely remove successive
cancellation from this part of the tree
and replace it with a repetition decoder
and the same thing with this guy here
this is a nice example of a single
parity-check node code and we have fast
parallel algorithms to do decoding of
those codes and so what we end up with
is a reduced problem where we have new
kinds of nodes that have even new kinds
of colors so this green node is
repetition decoder and this
orange node is a single parity-check
decoder and then portly they're not
successive okay so we can do these
Sheree do these fast okay well we saw
this SC decoding there so we have a
reduced problem will go into this but we
have all kinds of nodes that we can
identify and replace with fast parallel
decoders petition nodes single
parity-check codes we identify sometimes
combinations where we have the
combinations of both for limited code
size and also base to ml decoding for
some small sub codes in the tree okay so
we have actually a bunch of other ones
as well how does this work well this is
actually quite small polar code of
length 256 on the left this is the prune
tree after simplified SC decoding and
then you can see that we're gonna
identify these kinds of sub-code x' here
and this is the final tree we get with
fat we call fast sse decoding so you do
much less successive decoding than in
the standard se decoding algorithm
you'll see here that there's some half
nodes here this is actually some merging
we do to improve memory access I'm
leaving all the details out but it ends
up being pretty optimal now it's a pain
to do this by hand so we've actually
belt a compiler to do this for us you
put a polar code in and it automatically
goes through and optimizes it to find
the best assignment of these nodes to
minimize the latency the other thing we
do is we developed some generic hardware
that can decode any polar code and it
looks kind of like a processor it has
some decoding elements which are going
to implement these different decoder
types and what this compiler does is it
outputs some instructions a little
program which your decoder runs to
schedule the decoding of these nodes in
the right order so they were the
question
yes there is there's still successive
knits going on here this tree still
defines a sense of cancellation it's not
a smaller tree so yes there has to be
synchronization and this compiler spits
out the instructions in the right order
to do things so it's not completely
parallel but a lot of these these sub
trees are well the the the successive
still does who are throughput yeah so
how much I mean how how fast can we make
these things so for high rate codes we
have a decoder running on FPGA it'll
decode any code of lane 32k doesn't
matter you just put in different frozen
bit locations and long story short for a
very reasonable amount of hardware at a
profit about a hundred megahertz you get
the magic number of a gigabit per second
okay now how much of this is due to the
original success simplified algorithm
and how much is due to the fast
improvement to it well we took our
compiler and we just restricted it to
only using the the rate zero rate one
optimizations and not using any other
ones and you get about you know about
three times the improvement so but about
a third of a three times improvement
from SSE and then another three times
from using the fast techniques okay so
here's a snapshot of where we were we
had a hundred megabits per second you
know my Pemex work and then okay fast it
says see on an FPGA about a gigabit per
second and then last year there was an
ASIC at the villa size symposium which
actually implemented BP which is about
over 2 gigabits per second ok so how do
you situate these things well first of
all they're four different code lanes so
this was for one case it's for 32 okay
that might be a consideration megahertz
per megahertz I think this is he decoder
is actually faster okay if you made this
a 300 megahertz which in an ASIC would
be entirely reasonable it would be
faster so I mean they're about the same
but I do I have a hunch that SSE
decoding is actually more efficient than
VP decoding although there's still not
enough data points to know that for sure
ok so how do we get down to a hundred
mega gigabits per second so the idea is
actually very simple you unroll the tree
and pipeline it so here's an example for
a very short polar code where we've
already
identified that there's some repetition
codes and single parent check codes so
we put down some hardware to implement
the different operations we're going to
eat we're going to need some F and G
functions for the successive
cancellation here we're gonna need
repetition decoder at C decoder and then
some partial sum generators and we can
then pipeline the decoding of several
code words through this thing as they
come down information gets passed back
up here down to here and back up to here
and the code words follow through okay
now there is a price for this this is
really really inefficient so this we
just did this to see how fast we could
get lots of logic so this is actually
quite a big decoder it does
interestingly still fit on an FPGA it's
not completely impractical but it's much
much bigger than our previous work but
it's also much much faster so it's 118
could give us per second information
throughput so let's see the paper
actually we have submitted has a coded
throughput of 237 could give you which
is pretty fast and compared to the
previous fast fastest work it's you know
orders of magnitude faster but there is
a complexity price to pay so at least we
now know that things can go fast there's
no limit to how fast this can go don't
remember actually how many we had lead
the pipeline is in this particular but I
can get you that information
I don't think it's that deep actually
but we'll talk offline okay I'll try go
really faster so one thing we noticed
when we only developed this was that our
simulations ran really fast in software
so we started looking into this and we
realize that our hardware that we had
built on FPGA looks like a processor but
it looks like a modern processor it has
a very very parallel processing unit
from 128 processing elements at work in
parallel and a bunch of memory that's
pretty much what modern sim the
processor looks like and so we started
realizing that this might be a good
match for software-defined radio if you
look at something to find Radio ECC
actually is the second most intensive
operation need to do so there's some
motivation to to speed it up and looking
you do with modern codes well turbo
codes LDPC codes slowly could only do
recent results only a few megabits per
second per core usually you're limited
to one core because you have other
things to do on the other course so we
won't want to know can use polar codes
to improve the throughput here we were
told that if you could get 50 mega Spur
second that'd be something kind of
interesting so that's our goal so long
story short we optimized our software
first kasra we got about 150 megabits
per second for different code lengths
okay then we wrote a compiler to
optimize it basically what it does is it
takes away all the branches and does a
bunch of other tricks to make the code
vectorizable so it can be mapped to sim
D processors and this is all on a single
core on a core i7 I think and we have
you know a few hundred megabits per
second information bit through folks so
it's they're really fast okay this is
some latest work actually which is just
about to be submitted there's a couple
of different approaches to polar code in
software one approach is to decode a
bunch of frames in parallel so this is
legal and and others took that approach
and we optimized the decoding of a
single frame you get about the same
throughput over a gigabit per second on
a really fast processor which is quite
surprisingly you can do that but it's
they're very fast but the latency is
much better we think doing it this way
so we have actually pretty good latency
about 20 microseconds and very
high throughput and the comparison to
LDPC codes and software is actually very
favorable because you really can't do
that many iterations of how that see
decoding because it's so slow so then
things start to equalize in terms of
performance I don't have the results to
show but you can see that we can trade
off performance in same speed finally
I'll just briefly talk about improving
the finally the performance if you want
to make comparisons a bit per bit with
LDPC codes we saw that talent Vardy
showed you how using a CRC and then
listing coding you can get the same bit
error rate as LDPC codes so what are the
implications for implementation briefly
the way it works is you don't make a
choice hard choice at every step so in
the first step here decoding bit zero I
don't frozen to fine at zero but you
know bit one could be a zero or one so
why don't I go down both both paths and
the tree keeps growing but what I do is
I prune the tree and I only keep the L
best candidates and so I have a list of
size L I use the CRC to choose from
among the candidates at the and the list
and this actually it was a huge
improvement and very good performance
the problem is it's still very complex
so what does it look like to implement
this thing so we came up with an
architecture see there's a bunch of
decoders and a memory and we just we
shuffle information back and forth
basically it works for small list sizes
we can get for code level is 1k and
about 100 megabits per second so much
slower than SSE decoding but still
somewhat practical finally the last
thing we'll talk about cuz I only about
two minutes left is what about software
list decoders so we know that list
decoders are much slower than the
fastest of C decoders we introduced but
they have much better error correction
performance so why not come up with a
hybrid of the two
I said we did first thing you should do
is most code words are gonna be decoded
with fastest exceed so no problem do
that most of the time if the CRC fails
then go to this list
CRC decoder which will be slower but it
should only happen very infrequently
okay so if you have a performance of
fastest C that's out here in the list
CRC that's here we actually implemented
not quite the fast list CRC but the
SFC list here see we actually have a
fast linearity decoder now in the lab it
hasn't been published yet but it will be
very soon and for late 2k this is what
the performance looks like relatively
but the throughput what kind of
throughput should you get from this
hybrid system well as long as you have
signal-to-noise ratio that's high enough
you should get throughput that's
approximately approaching that apostacy
but you should get the aircraft
performance of the list decoder so here
are the results what we call the 2 step
decoder using a list of size 32 we have
a little bit of loss compared to Delta
BC code which is in black using 64
Alyssa 64 we can pretty much match the
frame error rate of an LDPC code of the
same length and dimension and then how
about implementation in software on a
core i7 if you look at the information
throughput in terms of megabits per
second the LDPC decoder is pretty
constant it's just pretty pretty slow a
few minutes per second but as I get to
higher and higher SNR's I really don't
use the list decoder for the polar code
very often so my throughput just goes up
really fast and I can get above this
magic number of 50 megabits per second
if I really want to match the LDPC code
ok I'm about forty or something but I
have a little bit of loss I can get up
to over 50 so this might show that
there's some interest in in
software-defined radio for using polar
codes
so in conclusion polar codes can have
excellent error correction performance
they also can have really good
throughput in up to even 100 gigabits
per second range so we need to do now is
to combine these these two ideas we have
to combine the throughput improvements
and the performance improvements and
once that's been done we believe that
this actually might be viable to use
polar codes and
the LDPC codes you were comparing
against this was the arrow to the last
time I showed you this was the arrow 2.3
am ethernet standard yes that's the code
yes do you remember what was the decorum
of it this black line here this I
believe I have to check this and I
believe it's some kind of corrected
minsum for the LDPC cord do you stop the
iterations as soon as the packet is
decoded or the inches on a fixed number
of iterations I'm surprised that the
complexity stays constant as the SNR
increases right that's probably four
oh no it is actually 4:30 maximum
iterations but it may stop earlier yeah
so be earlier given that your ser spent
to the minus eight whatever it should
stop much earlier how is it implemented
than only be seated coder so just saw
there's killed mince them they're not
that the implementation not that
algorithm right to use the SIMD before
you talked about using no I don't think
it's that we didn't we didn't go to
often really optimize the LCD color too
much
variations yes yes this tends to work
better for higher rate polar codes we
haven't tried it for a variety of
channel just really awgn choice end up
with this question
this makes sense to freeze extra
business award to choose special
configurations so that your population
yes yes a good question can you change
the which bit you freeze to and we have
done this and we see Manas may be eight
to ten percent speed up with no error
rate loss by by swapping some frozen
bits and information bits around the
border of reliable and not reliable to
get better compilation yes we've we've
done that and it works using somewhat in
the rate we haven't tried that actually
that's a good idea
no more questions okay second quarter
again